yeah they may have been reading the
headlines a little bit too much in green
bay the packers went to la to take on a
chargers team and a 30 000 seat soccer
stadium that was overrun by packers fans
and it didn't work aaron rodgers who had
had some unbelievable statistical
performances the past couple of weeks
thrust himself into the mvp conversation
he was 23 of 35 for 161 yards he
averaged 4.6 yards per attempt passer
rating of
85.5 which used to be hey that's not bad
now that's pathetic
and and uh the packers were pathetic
aaron rodgers had some strong comments
for the team after the game they weren't
obviously strong but when you read them
it's you get the message that that he
wasn't happy about something yeah with
the preparation with what the guys did
when they got to l.a whatever the case
may be right they did not button it up
as well as they needed to
and now the the packers uh who looked at
seven and one like one of the best teams
in the nfc now they're seven and two and
they're gonna have to answer some
questions yeah they definitely are i
mean another team that had the fought
brought to them uh especially like their
offensive line their offense in line got
pushed around couldn't create any holes
in the run game for aaron jones and then
usually usually that's okay because you
just go oh okay they can't run the ball
let's put rogers in shotgun and let him
take over you know like he did against
the raiders or like he did against the
lions or like he did against the chiefs
really the chiefs game wasn't a great
game by that offense either they only
won the chiefs game because number 12
was at quarterback the problem is in
these type of games when it gets to that
when you guy when you have guys like
bosa and ingram they're game changers
they're game wreckers and for a guy like
aaron rodgers who oh okay our team's not
playing good jump on my back guys i'll
carry us through he can't carry you
through if his old line can't pass
protect and he's got ingrambosa all over
him but i mean the packers i think this
is reality there's concerns with their
team i mean their defense has been
getting the ball moved on them
consistently here the last five or six
weeks so that's an issue i worry about
that and you know a little bit like we
talked about with the vikings in the
first hour you know if there's no
semblance of a run game there in green
bay
it hurts them why well you know they
don't have the greatest weapons in the
past game devonte adams is just getting
back and they really want to play to
that play-action pass game and if the
play if the run game's not working the
play-action pass game's huge for them
and of course it doesn't exist if you
can't run the ball very well and the
packers have the panthers at home this
week then they have their bi-week week
11. four of the last six games are on
the road for green bay yeah at the 49ers
at the giants and who knows that's one
of those just like at the chargers if
you don't have it buttoned up you aren't
going to win that game they're going to
rise up and they're going to take a
chunk out of your rear end then home
games against washington and chicago at
the vikings at the lions to finish the
season and all of a sudden the grip on
the nfc north a little tenuous for the
packers the only good news for the
packers the vikings lost the lions lost
the bears lost right so the net result
on the day for everyone in the nfc north
no big deal everyone lost although it
was a hell of an opportunity for a team
like the vikings for a team like the
lions imagine if the lions had won and
had gone to four three and one instead
of three four and one and they'd be
right there yeah and uh and you know
there's a lot of games this year the
lions could have won that they weren't
able to pull up hackers are not out of
the woods they're not but with the way
their defense plays you know especially
their interior defensive line you got
the carolina panthers you can run the
ball that's scary for them this week you
know you go by week you go to the 49ers
the best running team at all football
that's really scary you know i do think
there's a chance we you know see the
packers lose you know one or two more
games maybe three more games here down
the stretch i don't think the packers
are as a complete team
as the 49ers or the new orleans saints i
don't think they are i think those teams
are those two teams are a notch above
the green bay packers they just have a
great equalizer in number 12 that you
know
is dangerous on any given sunday but i
think full like well-rounded football
teams when you just talk about offense
and defensive line run game d you know
defense in general all those things the
saints and 49ers i think have shown that
they're in a little bit of a class of
their own in the nf
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports